let's let's shift gears to some big news
and big plans to hold the first ever
street race in nascar cup series history
cars will race through the streets of
chicago speeding past city landmarks and
it's all to celebrate nascar's 75th
season the 12 turn 2.2 mile race will be
the first in downtown chicago since 1956
when it was at soldier field long time
nascar driver kurt bush is expected to
drive in the race which will take place
next july bush has been racing
professionally for 23 years and is a
nascar cup series and daytona 500
champion he earned his 34th career cup
win in may and kurt is with us right now
thank you for joining us man how are you
doing absolutely thank you guys for
having me yeah so this is a first of its
kind
this will be a race through the streets
of chicago we were talking during a
commercial break and tony asked you the
question how do you prepare for
something like this versus what you
usually race oh this is huge i mean it's
like going to have a monaco
vibe and just to be in the streets and
then create that excitement for the city
center of chicago it's going to be
completely different and so yeah
simulation models will get us close
but that first friday practice that's
when when it's really going to get busy
out there and we'll see well strategy is
going to be the same whether it's kind
of drafting and you're kind of nudging
around each other or is it going to be
rougher because the confines are close
yeah i think it's more of a survival
things are gonna be rough uh the asphalt
transitions onto the concrete just the
different bumps in in the city streets
they're not as nice as our normal race
tracks and also in a normal racetrack if
you spin out you go into that grassy
area in the middle or maybe hit the wall
you don't want that but in a in a city
setting it's nothing but wall yeah so
there's a lot of a lot of wiggle room
that isn't going to exist i know it's
for this but it's part of it well the
other thing kurt is it's it's 12 turns
in just over two miles that's what i
worry about for you are you worried are
you afraid does completely different
mean completely scary to you or you say
no i got this no i love it i actually
went and pre-ran the course
right before our wisconsin race a month
ago and you come off of one of the turns
and you're looking straight at the
museum and then we're on lake shore
drive and then you come back out onto
i think it's michigan ave and it just
has a great vibe all the way around and
that area is normally used for like
lollapalooza concerts so there's gonna
be so much extra action outside the race
hold on you pre-ran the race was this in
a rental car there's a rental car
i had a days of thunder i was wondering
about that too i was talking about that
too no no tires were harmed on that one
good now you mentioned it's it's going
to be a great vibe chicago is a great
sports
place like they love every sport from
football basketball baseball hockey
everything in in between what do you
hope this does for chicago
well it's to create the buzz for not
just the city but for our sport it
creates this ticket that people want to
come and be part of
and just be part of this i'm i've been
in this sport 23 years and this to me is
like one of those kid in a candy store
moments of i want to be part of this and
i'm glad that i'm having the chance to
drive next year for the team and
then i might be done driving after that
i was wondering whoa whoa whoa
i was wondering about that kurt because
you are 43 that's considered and no
offense that's considered older in your
business over the age of 40. when you
just said i might
be done after this do you really mean
that i was wondering do you have a game
plan about retiring so there's a few
different options and for me the team
which gave me so much respect about a
month ago they said you can drive as
long as you want to drive for us we
really appreciate you driving uh-huh
well we need to start to look at
who the next new talent is you know
where the sponsorships are but are you
ready are you even kind of ready it's
part but maybe not so i'll keep driving
you're not sure we just signed a new guy
tyler reddick to 2311. okay what do you
what do you like about it is this the
first time you're talking about
potentially retiring it's out there all
the time um but no no no not really yeah
but what do you like about the sport
still
my favorite part is oh it's that first
lap of practice each weekend why is that
adrenaline
of of that speed in that moment but also
because of the team they built this car
it's very safe to drive and it's fun and
i now get the chassis and chassis set up
all dialed in
if you retire you can always come back i
mean just ask jordan you know and that
yeah he's part of the ownership group
right or you could switch sports for a
little while you know go to formula one
now we're definitely gonna have a lot of
fun uh this next little bit and this
chicago street race again is just
unprecedented bold bold move for our
sport and it's it's fun the way that
nascar is moving some of our tracks
around and going to new venues and your
your brother also races i mean is there
a sibling rivalry yes i have that pesky
little brother
that's great i love race you guys are so
good together too you're right we are
now at that good spot yeah in our career
and um we did have a couple run-ins
early but now with drafting positioning
on track uh we're definitely helping
each other racing these toyotas one of
the best in the business man you're a
living legend truly truly when they
tweet the car for the for the chicago
street race i hope they put the radio in
maybe a speaker in the back
be bumping around there you see out
there kurt busch thank you very much